well welcome everyone i have a very
special interview with a man by the name
of fred evrad
so welcome fred thank you for being on
here thank you for having me
so the reason why i wanted to do this
interview uh fred is because um
uh
there's been another interview i did on
a cancer survivor and if someone gets
the diagnosis of cancer
unfortunately it's
it puts a person in a state of fear and
it's very hard to make decisions and
we just want to give options we want to
give options for people we want to give
alternative solutions that you can look
at and evaluate and
and we're not saying to do this solution
but we are saying that there is stuff
out there that you should know about if
you have cancer
now
fred you were diagnosed actually in 2020
with colon cancer it was a stage three
but it was on the borderline of a stage
four right correct yes absolutely
and um
did you have
and i'm gonna kind of go through this in
little pieces did you have uh symptoms
initially that cause you to get a test
yes
yes and that's where that's where my
story is a little
a little weird and where i didn't
necessarily make the right decision um
i'm 50 years old i've been a martial
artist my entire life i was born in a
martial arts family
always had a
pretty good healthy lifestyle
from my parents all the way to my
adulthood
we i never had
alcohol in my life i never smoked i
never drink soda in my entire life i
don't eat junk food
organic been doing intermittent fasting
for 20 years so even though there's a
colon cancer history in my family both
my father and my grandfather died of it
i was so sure that my lifestyle would
protect me and that genetic wouldn't
catch me
i didn't i didn't pay attention to the
sign
i started to have inflammation visible
on my skin a little bit of psoriasis on
my elbows and my knees and then the
inflammation get a little worse and i
start having a little bit of blood uh in
my stool
looking at the color of the blood i
thought that's probably an amoroid or
something like that it doesn't look like
cancer blood you know it's very bright
very light color and
i didn't do what i should have done and
if if i did had a test
uh at that time i would have probably
caught the cancer at stage one which
would have been a much easier battle
unfortunately i looked the other way
and uh six months later it was getting
worse so then i finally decided to get
tested i went back to france i live in
the us now went back to france and uh
had myself tested
and the diagnosis was there it's a stage
three almost for colon cancer
uh one of the few that apparently are
completely genetic
and uh
and just like you said when you get that
diagnosis you you freeze you don't know
what to do it's complete action and
thinking innovation and it's really hard
to fight the medical system and to try
to see if there are other options
yeah i could imagine i could only
imagine um
okay so you were diagnosed and i think
it was close to the rectum the that was
it a tumor right yeah yeah it was a 10
centimeter tumor so i don't know maybe
four inches for five inches
started in the rectum all the way to the
the lower part of the column
because of the size the doctors told me
you have to go very fast i mean you have
50 chance of survival with your history
plus the size of the tumor it doesn't
look good so you have to be you have to
be fast
and what they
offered me was
24 sessions of chemotherapy
six months of radiation plus an
operation at the end
and
when i when i when i when i heard that
and when i start looking at
what are my what are the odds for me if
i go that way
immediately i thought to myself okay i'm
gonna do something different and and
i've been into ketogenic diet i've been
into intermittent fasting for quite a
while i used to do a little bit of
prolonged fasting once in a while so i i
knew that i had the tool
what i didn't know is why
didn't those tools worked before
and i have no idea i don't have the
answer my answer is maybe i didn't do
everything at once which i did what i
knew i was i was sick
but uh basically what i did
the moment the moment i i i woke up from
the three-day shock of the diagnosis
i did the 21-day fast
after that 21-day fast the tumor was
reduced of 50
then i found your videos
and uh and i start to really look into
the ketogenic diet for cancer and i went
on a strict 100 organic ketogenic diet
with internet and fasting one meal a day
and then a friend of mine started to
send me some information about
supplements then i met ghee
who also was a big part of
of my of my story and then i started the
the protocol that that he's doing and
that you and you and he are looking into
i think at the moment so so i want to
just i want to interject because those
people that are maybe new to uh this
concept uh there's a gentleman by the
name of guy tenenbaum who i interviewed
and
we worked together he had stage four
cancer and he no longer has cancer and
so
um
you found his videos and there's a
nutritional protocol
that
is based on some really interesting
research that we also help funded and
many of you watching have helped funded
this research in
europe
which we just now completed i mean it
took a while to complete it and
get the research published okay in a
major journal which i'm gonna put the
link down below which is very exciting
i'm gonna do a separate video on that
but it's
it's a um
you know
guys success um was
a combination of primarily fasting
and of course the diet
um but this particular study was not
looking at fasting
because apparently in europe they have a
um they have a problem with fasting
um
or putting mice through fasting because
they think it's starvation or something
so um so we just did a nutritional
protocol and the success was
phenomenal so so in other words when you
got with guy he
he uh kind of advised you on probably
his nutritional protocol right yeah
absolutely so the first step for me was
the 21 day fast then after i went on the
street ketogenic diet with intermittent
fasting that was the basis after that i
implemented many of the things that i
knew from my martial art training
breathing meditation
ice cold bath in the winter as well as
the summer uh mini trampoline to to to
really reboot my lymphatic system
everything that i could think of i tried
to attack that cancer from as many
angles as possible i also did a mini
psychotherapy with a friend of mine
who's a psychotherapist doctor in france
and i really try to to see okay where
where else can i do something about that
tumor and then i finally met uh
guy and and your your research and i
implemented
uh melatonin
uh green tea vitamin d3
zinc
uh and and few other supplements
to to really help me finish the the
healing completely
and bottom line
i was diagnosed in september
10 i think excuse me if the dates are
not perfect i put everything in my book
for those interested all the dates and
everything but sometimes i forget um and
four months later exactly on january 9 i
was completely healed and and
cancer-free
incredible and so that was four months
you went from
you went from this tumor that was uh 10
centimeters yeah
down to zero
um
so this is unheard of and uh so the
doctors now this is what i'm curious
about how did the doctors react when
they saw that you well they probably
blamed it on
your
your the medical treatment i don't know
what what or what did they say when they
you know well you don't have so
after my after my fast i did i did the
five the 21 day fast without any
previous medical treatment so that's the
first thing i did
and it was so encouraging that i i've
decided to continue doing my treatment
all natural
but
i was in a lot of pain
i was in so much pain
you have no idea it was
i
if it wasn't for my my wife and and my
family i think at some point i would
have just dropped it and jump out the
window it was so painful
in the abdominal area yeah yeah rectum
and abdominal area so i talked to my
oncologist
and he said okay
here is my offer i know you want to do
it naturally but why what why don't we
try
six sessions of chemo instead of 24 just
six to reduce the tumor a little faster
and then release some of the pain
so i said okay let's do that of course i
continued my research before doing the
chemo i found the dr walter longo's
research on fasting and chemo so i
fasted and i only did three sessions of
chemotherapy so session number one i
fasted the day before the day during and
the day after
no symptom nothing i was perfectly fine
the second session i decided not to fast
just to go on a light ketogenic diet to
see if it was the fasting who helped me
or if it was my immune system or my body
because of the martial arts i don't i
didn't know so i didn't fast on the
second one but i was very very careful
with my food
i was sick like a dog
like a dog it was horrible
the third session of chemotherapy i
fasted again
nothing no symptom
and compared to all my friends around me
when i was doing the chemo i was the
only one not to lose one single air
nothing i didn't lose my hair i didn't i
wasn't sick i didn't lose much weight i
mean because of the fasting i really
really
did went through the chemo quite quite
easily so so so uh for those of you
watching um it's important to know that
when you fast you
greatly greatly reduce the symptoms of
chemotherapy
and
i mean it's almost like the body goes in
this protect mode
so that that's basically what happened
right yeah absolutely and and like i say
that was i was already
i had a little bit of knowledge about it
and i tried
it worked
and that's it so after three sessions
depends the pain was completely gone so
i told my oncologist here in the u.s
look i want to stop and the guy looked
at me like i was crazy it's working it
doesn't work on everyone it's working on
you why don't you why don't you continue
and i said no i got what i want
the pain is gone now i want to do it my
way
he finally said yes they took away my
plug let me go
and
everything else was fasting
ketogenic diet and i was on a very
restrictive ketogenic diet
because of my colon inflammation i
couldn't eat fibers
i couldn't take
anything except
organic grass-fed ribeyes and green
vegetable juice that's all i ate for
three months every single day revised
and then people tell me meat gives you
cancer but for me it killed me but
again and i think you mentioned it a lot
in your videos organic grass-fed
free-range animals
yeah grass-fed grass finished yeah
absolutely yeah so that's a really key
point uh which is
just because it's grass-fed doesn't mean
it's grass finish very important
especially for um i mean
there's a massive research
uh project going on that right now i
will put that link down below i just
talked about it but so how did when you
when you finally after three months um
shrunk this tumor what what did the
doctors say what did they how did they
um
respond
that was a it was a funny day so i go
for my uh my last mri
and
one of the nurses over there is a very
good friend of mine i've known her
before of the cancer and stuff like that
so once in a while she looked at my file
and gave me some updates before the
doctor sees me and it's what happened so
she calls me and she said i had the
results of your last mri in front of me
and it's really weird they don't they
don't mention the tumor at all and they
don't find any evidence and she said
look fred i'm not an oncologist i'm just
a nurse
i don't want to give you get your hopes
too high you see the doctors in two days
wait and see
so i'm already like oh yes
so i wait for two days go see the
oncologist and he's there in his office
and he told me he tells me mr evrad
i don't say that very often in my line
of work but you are this is free
wow
wish you could i wish you could
have said can i put that on recording
can i put that on the record
probably uh not but uh yeah so so
it's interesting you would think that
you'd probably go wow what did you do
let me let me recommend this to other
patients the problem is they they're the
medical doctors are stuck between a rock
and a hard place because they have to
recommend this the
medicine and they can't necessarily go
outside the box
um so that is the problem that the
system like you said in in your other
recording the system is
is is pr a problem not the doctors it's
like yeah yeah absolutely and i am
thankful i am thankful to western
medicine to to have taken my pain away
i'm thankful to my my oncologist who
have been open-minded enough to to
follow me you know in my trip and and
yet
keep following me with my blood test
every month my mri every three months my
colonoscopy every year so the guy was
really following me and and i am really
thankful for that but yeah they didn't
they didn't really ask me what i did
they were not really interested i tried
to mention it to mention fasting and
believe it or not and again i'm not
pointing fingers or anything they do
what they can but during chemotherapy
the nurses go through patient to patient
offering them coke and cookies just to
make them feel better and when they when
they reach me i said no sorry i'm
fasting
and i was about to tell her do you know
that sugar feeds cancer but of course in
front of everybody i didn't want to you
know to make her feel embarrassed or
anything so where was my responsibility
toward the others in the room or the
respect for the nurse and the doctors so
i was in a in a weird place and i i
didn't say much but i told her you know
what it's i'm doing fasting and it
really helps and at the end of the day
she bought my book and she was very
interested but the doctors not so much
right
question um
did you find
um like
first of all you're you probably didn't
have a weight problem you don't have a
lot of weight to lose
um because i watched your some of your
videos um on your site um how did you
deal with fasting for 21 days with your
weight did you lose a lot of weight tell
me about yeah
so
it's it's complicated i didn't have a
lot of weight to lose i was in in the
one of the best shape of my life before
the cancer i was 70 kilos which is which
is good for me uh
nine percent body fat nine or ten
percent body fat i was in big condition
doing crossfit martial art boxing
parkour
and and i was 48 49 at the time
and thanks to that physical condition it
really helped me take also some of the
some of the the cancer
but um
when i when i did my fast
i lost weight but the worst was the
month after that so that's really where
the cancer was the most aggressive and
that's when i decided to do to do the
chemo because i was in so much pain and
the inflammation was so huge
and i went from 70 kilos to 49 kilos
there was nothing but bones and a little
skin the hard thing for me was to gain
the weight back which i'm almost there
now it's been a year and a half
and uh i'm 66 67 kilos few more kilos
and and i'll be okay but it took a while
to get my my weight back but i never had
problem to lose weight
yeah that's that is always the challenge
is how do you fast and keep
keep your weight or because if you're
thin you know it creates just a problem
of how are you going to do this but okay
so as far as your your fasting though um
you did a 21 uh day fast
and then after that
you went to one meal a day yes
and then did you do any additional
prolonged fasting after that yes
so the first 21 day fast was at the very
beginning then i did one meal a day
ribeyes and vegetable juice basically
because i couldn't take the veggies with
all the fibers
yeah and that was for three months until
christmas and december
and then christmas comes and my mom
comes from france to visit us and she's
a michelin star pastry chef
oh so
everything i mean
talking about jumping
out of the wagon that was me for a week
so between christmas and new year for
spies and pasta and pizza everything i
was so frustrated that i couldn't eat
before so i had a week of cheat
and after that week
i didn't feel bad i didn't feel worse
but
the next mri was coming in two weeks and
i was a little scared of the result
because of the cheating so i did another
21 day fast but not 21 days straight i i
fast during the week and ate during the
weekend ketogenic diet and i did that
for three weeks
okay so all together
on the weekends did you do one meal
today
on the weekends i went back to my
routine of a kilo diet one meal a day
okay
and and nothing at all during the week
and that's where at the end of that last
prolonged fast i went for my last mri
and pet scan and blood work and that's
when they told me there's no more tumor
you're cancer-free
wow so you did two
21-day fast but the second one was just
during the weekday and then
and then right now
to maintain what you're maintaining how
many meals a day are you consuming
usually one
but uh sometimes two it depends on my
workout it depends you know how much
exercise i did that day
usually i try to stick to one
okay
um
what about um
i want to know a little bit more about
before you had blood in your stool
or a problem that you started to
recognize like there's some skin issues
like how many years ago was that was
that like um 2000
that was basically the six months before
the diagnosis so i was diagnosed in
september and from april may something
like that i started to have a psoriasis
rush and uh
and uh blood on my stool
so what i'm curious about and just you
might there not might not be anything
but um
was there any other uh thing going on
like
with your bowels did you
did you um go on an antibiotic did you
go through a lot of stress
did you um is there any potential thing
that could have triggered this thing
right before you started having skin
problems that you could think of
yeah you're absolutely right so
basically the tehran was there because
of my family history but the trigger was
definitely psychological a few things
happen number one
my wife and i were french but we used to
live in singapore we lived in singapore
for 10 years and we moved from singapore
to the us and the green card process was
a nightmare
we waited for three years
spent
thousands and thousands and thousands of
dollars it was a lot of stress going to
the embassy being rejected going to the
embassy being accepted so that was a lot
of stress and we lost a lot of money
that's the first thing second kovid hit
and all my schools i have 20 schools
around the world uh martial art schools
and all my schools they all close at one
so wow no no no money
no nothing and that's exactly when
when i start to have the the symptoms
okay
makes a lot of sense because you just
kind of kicked in those genes
uh from an epigenetic which is above
genetics
yeah that makes total sense
for those of you that are watching um
there's some basic information you need
to know like
cancer cells originate from normal cells
the mitochondria get damaged and then
the cells start to adapt to this
kind of a prehistoric type of metabolism
where it can now run on
a different fuel can ferment fuel
so now it's it's a cancer cell and
it
loses its ability to die or commit
suicide like healthy cells actually um
go through this
process where they can they only live
for so long but cancer cells can lose
that
um in this certain state
so the real
like everything
that a person should do should
kind of align it with um
preventing damage to the mitochondria
and the cells and
you know this is why you have like
excessive chronic stress um
carcinogens
um chronic consumption of
um omega-6 inflammatory foods
and sugars
that can actually create damage to the
mitochondria
so
and then when you're
going through recovery
there um
there's so many theories out there so
much confusion but
what i would recommend someone is to
your primary
thing you should do is um fasting
prolonged fasting hands down that is
like going to be the most important
thing but then there's a nutritional
protocol
see there's something unique about
cancer cells that i want to share that i
will do a separate video on this the
cancer cell
you have strategies of starving the
cancer cell of fuel
but then you also
have another strategy which
which we did a study on which you're
you're starving the cancer cell
uh from its structural membrane raw
material
so there's a certain
pathway
um called i'm not going to tell you the
long name but it's called scott and
there's a certain like a door that you
can feed the uh the cell certain raw
material that build the membrane around
the cancer cell and it's you it's
there's a unique part of this that
it doesn't interfere with normal cells
so
um there's what's called
scot inhibitors
that block and there's natural scot
inhibitors that can block this pathway
and
this nutritional protocol
took like a handful of these scot
inhibitors and we did the study on mice
and we
gave them
this these scot inhibitors and then we
compared it to a control group that was
taking a very powerful chemo drug
and um it was twice as effective as that
drug without the side effects and that's
not even using fasting so
in other words i would combine
the nutritional protocol
with this fasting and i think
you you did you did that but you also
took it one step further which i'm
totally
i would totally recommend too with
stress everything you did to reduce
stress and you did the
you know cold ice baths in the winter
which is very painful that you did those
and you
you did everything which
which is just remarkable and that's what
i would do to recommend to like just
start compounding
and um
every little thing is gonna help but
it's definitely
a mind trick that you have to overcome
because
you have
certain people telling you oh no that's
not gonna work and putting doubt in your
mind you have to go this route but i
would always want to know and i don't
know if you asked the doc
did you ask the doctor if you did just
the chemo like they said the radiation
the surgery
what is the chances of long-term
survival and not just 20 years they told
me 50 but as you know they usually count
they usually make their stats from three
years sometimes five but no more and
according to many studies which i'm sure
you are familiar with uh after five
years it's closer to two to three
percent
so the prognosis after five years it's
just like they only go up like if you
survive five years it's like a 100
success rate to them like yeah exactly
no it's like no we want to know um
long term and so that's where that is
where you need to if you have cancer
start talking to the doctors about doing
your research because
um that's kind of an area a big huge uh
hole in the bucket where as far as
long-term survival and
um okay quality of life also like you're
alive after five years fine but what can
you do
right
and for me it was critical because i'm a
martial art instructor it's my it's my
job but uh and there was no way that i
would stop physical activities or or
doing my things not only because it's my
profession but also because it makes me
happy and that's what i love to do
but you were right before when you said
cancer is multifactorial therefore the
healing must be multifactorial as well
and it's very important and i for me
like i told you before i used fasting
intermittent fasting ketogenic diet
ice cold bath
mini trampoline
the scot inhibitor protocol
everything i could do and every time you
make a decision there's another doctor
another study telling you don't do that
it's the worst like vitamin c
one of my doctor friend in paris told me
high doses of vitamin c three six grams
uh if you can't have iv you do it uh
orally but it's gonna be limited but six
gram would be good and some other people
no no no no cancer grow with vitamin c
and at some point you have to make a
choice and it's really hard and i really
feel for the people who are sick and
don't know what to do i receive hundreds
of emails every day people asking me
should i do this or not this i don't
know i'm not a doctor yeah but for me
i decided to go along with vitamin c and
d3 and zinc and all the things that
people said ah you know we're not sure
we don't know there's no evidence
well it worked for me i guess the the
moral of this story the lesson of the
story is to you you have to um
take it to the next level and you have
to learn how to create your own health
and not
um put it in someone else's hands
you really need to bite the bullet and
learn how to create your own health on a
daily basis because we have things that
are countering our health uh on a
daily basis so
you can't just sit by and uh let someone
else do it for you
absolutely i couldn't agree more and uh
it's
it's difficult because like we said at
the beginning when you get diagnosed
it's
it's terrible it's really hard your
nervous system your your mind everything
freezes and uh and all you can do is
follow what the doctors are telling you
and
they're doing their best but they're not
always up to date with the research and
they have a protocol they have to follow
or they can get sue and it's complicated
for an oncologist to to tell you hey why
don't you do something else but you have
to do your own research you have to take
your your survival into your own hands
it's your choice to follow the doctor's
advice and protocol or not that's a 100
personal choice but it doesn't stop
you from doing your research and and
going a little bit further than the
information that the doctor gave you and
researching and learning about cancer
everything you can about cancer
for me was a very important part of my
healing
it was not enough that some doctor told
me you have cancer it's almost incurable
here are your chances good luck no i was
not satisfied with that let's open some
books let's go on google and let's go on
the pubmed and read all the scientific
literature
about cancer and fasting and cancer and
ketogenic diet and cancer as a metabolic
disease and all of that all those
research i spend night and day reading
it and and and doing something with it
yeah yeah and uh someone gives you some
some some data
that you're like that freaks you out
just really make sure that you realize
that maybe in an opinion it's not a fact
and so a fact is different from an
opinion
opinions may or may not be true
uh facts are true and so someone gives
you a lot of opinions it's actually
it's probably worse than them
worse
it's especially worse if it's a an
opinion that could be based on
incomplete information so because
unfortunately the way the whole system
works is there
there's a lot of money to be made and
unfortunately it's like
you can't freely even talk about some of
these alternative
treatments without being
shut down
so i'm really really
happy with this interview because you
just shared a lot of great data for
people to
use in their own healing and
so i wanted to say thank you fred i'm
going to i want to put your website down
below and then
um just so people can see what you do
and also
guys website tunnelball
i saw that he tried to log on but just
tell him i was right in the middle of
the interview
but um
and i will also put the protocol if
someone wants to know this nutritional
protocol i'll put a link down below i'm
not i don't i do not sell these products
i don't want to sell these products you
have to find them on your own
the last thing i want to do is
give people claims that i have some
magical cure i am not going to say that
so um
so thank you so much fred i really
appreciate your sharing and this is very
valuable and uh we'll stay in
communication okay absolutely thank you
for having me